usemos ahora nuestros conocimientos
sobre conjuntos para que suba un poco de
sangre al cerebro para esto ha definido
algunos conjuntos que contienen no tan
sólo números contienen también colores
unas estrellas amarillas como éstas y lo
que queremos es encontrar cuál es el
conjunto que resulta esta operación tan
loca donde se usa complemento relativo
intersección unión complemento absoluto
te reto a que hagan la prueba y trates
de encontrar este conjunto ataquemos el
problema entonces la clave aquí es ir
quitando paréntesis tal y como lo harías
si resolverás una expresión algebraica y
después de ir resolviendo esos
paréntesis podremos encontrar esperemos
el conjunto resultante empecemos por
encontrar el complemento relativo de cmb
o la diferencia debe menos c es decir
que resulta hacia el conjunto b le
quitamos los elementos de c veamos
entonces que resulta el complemento
relativo del cmb o b - es el conjunto b
al cual le vamos a quitar aquellos
elementos que también están en si
empezamos a analizar ser
pero no está en ce por lo cual 0 es un
elemento de b
1717 estén se lo vamos a quitar de la
diferencia debe menos 3 también estén ce
por lo cual no está en vez de azul azul
no está en ser por lo cual está en la
diferencia db - c azul está en la
diferencia de b - esta estrella dorada
si éste se la extraemos del conjunto y
está el complemento relativo de cmb
consta de 0 y azul es el conjunto cuyos
elementos son 0 y azul escrito en azul
déjame cerrar el conjunto ahora se pone
interesante vamos a obtener el
complemento absoluto de eso déjame
escribir esto por acá tenemos el
complemento de c en el complemento
absoluto de eso van a ser todas las
cosas todos los objetos de escribirlo
bien el conjunto de todos los objetos
el universo en el conjunto universal que
no son que no son
ni 10 ni un azul déjame ponerlo en azul
ni un azul esto es lo más que podemos
establecer no hemos definido un conjunto
universal como tal pero sabemos que
tiene números que tiene algunos colores
que tiene algunas estrellas entonces lo
único que puedo establecer que este es
el conjunto de todos los objetos en el
universo que no son ni un cero ni una
azul bien lo que hemos encontrado hasta
el momento es esto de aquí esto de aquí
que corresponde a esto que acabamos de
calcular este lo que hemos encontrado y
ahora necesitamos encontrar la
intersección de a con lo que acabamos de
encontrar la intersección de a con el
complemento absoluto del complemento
relativo de c en b entonces a
intersección de complemento de cmb y el
complemento absoluto de eso que resulta
entonces esto va a ser la intersección
del conjunto a y el conjunto de todos
los objetos en el universo que no son ni
un cero ni un azul básicamente son los
objetos que satisfacen ambas condiciones
se encuentra en el conjunto a y se
encuentran en el conjunto de
objetos en el universo que no son ni 10
ni unasur veamos entonces qué es esto el
número tres se encuentre nada y se
encuentra en el conjunto de objetos en
el universo que no son ni 10 ni una azul
incluimos a 3 el 7 se encuentra en a y
se encuentra el conjunto de objetos en
el universo que no son ni un 0 ni un
azul el 7 está incluido el número menos
5 cumple ambas condiciones el número 0
se encuentre nada pero no se encuentra
en este conjunto porque el número 0 no
está en el conjunto de objetos del
universo que no son ni un cero ni una
azul por lo cual lo incluimos al cero y
el número 13 está en a y está en el
conjunto de objetos en el universo que
no son ni un cero y un azul incluimos al
13 entonces hemos simplificado bastante
las cosas todo este rollo que tenemos
aquí este rollo que corresponde a esto
es simplemente este conjunto bien ahora
queremos encontrar el complemento
relativo de esto en a vamos a escribirlo
queremos
el complemento relativo del conjunto 375
13 con respecto a creo que me juego
escribirá para que veamos como como se
calcula entonces es el conjunto a qué es
esto de acá es 37 menos 50 y 13 y este
es el convento relativo
voy a poner iba a poner menos pero no
voy a poner complemento relativo del
conjunto que hemos obtenido acá que es
37 menos 5 13 básicamente a partir de
este conjunto extra estos los elementos
que están en este otro conjunto y esto
es igual a el 3 lo vamos a eliminar
eliminamos el 3 eliminamos el 7
eliminamos el menos 5 eliminamos el 3 y
sólo nos resulta el 0 el conjunto que
tiene al 0 como elemento así es que esto
de aquí es el conjunto que tiene
únicamente al 0 como elemento veamos
entonces a que corresponde 20 sección se
ve intersección se es el conjunto de
elementos que están
en b y que están en c veamos calculemos
lo entonces 0 está en b pero 0 no estén
se muestra la intersección 17 está en b
y está en c entonces está en la
intersección el número 3 está en b y
estén set también está en la
intersección entonces azul está en b
pero no estén c no está en la
intersección y la estrella dorada está
en ambos está en la intersección este es
entonces b intersección c tomemos ahora
la unión de esto que es el conjunto que
contiene únicamente al 0 con 20 el
sección c y lo que tenemos es suenan las
fanfarrias por el resultado final el
conjunto que contiene los elementos de
ambos conjuntos es decir el conjunto que
contiene al 0 el 17 el 3 y la estrella
dorada la estrella dorada y ahora sí
hemos
ese no es el color adecuado ahora si
hemos concluido